young children and in youth
mana so govari was appointed prime
minister of the solomon islands in 2019
for the fourth time
now the election set for next year has
been delayed and his term has been
extended until 2024.
sogavare fast tracked a bill for
constitutional reform to postpone the
vote the prime minister says the island
nation can't afford to host the pacific
games in 2023 and go to the polls he
holds a majority in the country's
parliament and the contentious bill was
passed easily
the process of making decisions this
house mr speaker and in any democratic
system sir is by by members casting
revolts
but it's triggered condemnation from the
opposition it's labelled the move a
power grab and yet another attempt by
the prime minister to undermine
democracy australia had offered to help
fund the elections to avoid the delay
the sagavari government described that
as foreign interference accepted the
offer but still delayed the vote
i don't think it means that the
controversy goes away
i think there will be ongoing
disgruntlement
not just from the parliamentary
opposition but from others within the
wider society of solomon islands um and
i think we can expect to hear
commentary um from various quarters in
the in the ensuing weeks and months
a secret security deal with beijing
allows chinese police and law
enforcement officers to be based in the
island's capital honiara analysts say
that agreement and prolonging sagavari's
leadership could benefit china and
strengthen the partnership
in light of recent decisions that sort
of ra government has made such as
banning foreign vessels from docking
in salmon islands water
censorship
censorship of the national broadcaster
the secret security deal that solomon
islands signed with china
all of these um serve to increase the
executive power of the sagavari
government so
has served as prime minister three times
before this but wasn't popular enough to
finish a term he says delaying the next
election will be a one-off with no date
set for 2024.
sarah clark
al jazeera